hi Samuel Leeds here and in this video
I'm going to be giving you some absolute
golden nuggets to how you can find
properties heavily below market value
[Music]
you may hear a professional investors
always using the term bmv which stands
for below market value and the very
first thing this is really really
important if you're looking to buy
discounted promises if you're looking to
get a really good deal then what you
need to be doing is you need to be
finding a motivated sellers and not
being a motivated buyer the very worst
thing that you can be is a motivated
buyer someone who is really desperate
because you've just watched homes under
the hammer and you're like oh I really
want to buy a house and you've got money
in the bank and you're really motivated
and you get really excited maybe fall in
love with a property that you see on the
market you think oh my gosh that's so
nice that make such a good investment
property and then you get emotionally
attached when emotions are high
intelligence is low and when you are a
motivated buyer you're going to end up
paint over the odds
so instead you need to be a cool calm
and collected investor finding and
working with motivated sellers so how do
you find motivated sellers and why would
someone be in a position where they're
prepared to pass you their house 10 20
30 % below the true market value well
there's many reasons who these people
might be it might be that they are maybe
going through a problem they might have
just just be having good divorce you
know I mean I came across one lady who
was selling the house at suits a low
price just to spite her ex-husband
because they owned the house together
now it's nuts it's crazy and you know we
don't know what the reasons might be
necessarily people sometimes think you
know you're you're taking advantage of
the vulnerable you're finding people in
desperate situations no not at all we're
not putting anyone in any bad situations
what we're doing is we're finding them
in a particular situation and then we're
giving them what they want it might be
that they found their dream home and
they're about to move to Florida and in
order to get their dream home they need
to sell their house and they've a pair
to say fast for a discounted price
because they need a certain amount of
money in order to move on to do what
they're doing it might be that they're
about to go repossessed and the bank is
going to take the house off them and
they're going to lose the house because
they can't pay the mortgage and you're
going to buy off them and although
you're buying getting a real discount
which is great it's that for them it's
the lesser of two evils so you're
actually helping them so this isn't
about exploiting people this is about
you running a business trying to get
bargain properties and finding people
where it's actually a win-win and of
course you know they might not be in the
best situation in the world but it's
going to be the lesser of two evils and
you buying it off them at a discounted
rate is better than the other option so
that's the key
be cool calm collected find motivated
sellers so how do you find these types
of motivated sellers well they're
everywhere you can find them online you
can go on and really love a website
called Gumtree what I like to do is go
on gumtree if they're setting the house
on gumtree they've got to be pretty
motivated because come on who puts their
house on the country for sale so what I
do is I look for properties on gumtree
and I search from oldest listed and I
find all the properties that have been
on gumtree
for months or maybe even years that they
can't sell and I'll just phone them up
and say hey why can't you sell this
house what is the problem find out their
issue find out why they can't say what
the problem is and then see if I can
overcome that so that's one way Gumtree
next is tell everybody what you do tell
the world that you are a property
investor put on your face book that you
are maybe maybe you say I'm not a
property investor or a plumber no you're
a plumber and property investor tell the
world that you're looking to buy
properties and then what will happen is
I mean oh I get between twenty and
thirty messages a day on social media
from people that are stuck well they've
got a property they need to get rid off
just because everyone knows that I'm a
property investor so tell the world that
you are a property investor number three
build relationships with estate agents I
think that a good relationship with an
agent is a lot better than a good deal
because if you've got a good relation of
an estate agent they're gonna be tensed
about to pass you all the best
properties before they even go on the
market so make friends in estate agents
take them out for coffee
show them that you're serious if you've
got funds in place show them
you're financially qualified tell them
what you're looking for so that's just a
few ways that you can find motivated
sellers and get your foot in the door to
get in these types of deals so there's
just a few ways but there's many more
and the more motivated sellers that
you're dealing with at one given time
the less motivated you'll be because
you've got lots of choices so it's going
to mean you can get even better deals
now once you found these potential
properties you found these motivated
sellers how are you gonna secure this
property at such a good bargain price
well here's my tip for you first thing
you need to do is you need to find out
not what the asking price is many
amateur investors get mixed up between
the market value and the asking price
they could be asking you for a million
pounds for the problem so it might only
be worth four hundred thousand pounds so
the what the seller is asking for is
irrelevant you need to be able to work
out what the true current market value
is on the house now we want something
called the property investors crash
course where we show you how to value
any house one of the ways that we teach
this three but one of the ways is we
teach you to look at what has sold not
selling but what sold in the street
recently that is similar and you can do
that for free on Rightmove by looking at
the house prices tab at the top of right
mr. credit UK so once you know what the
current true market value is on the
property you're then gonna be able to
say okay the house is worth one hundred
thousand pounds oh I want to buy at the
80 or whatever it is that you might want
to buy it for now never put the offer in
first if you're speaking to the vendor
direct always make them give the first
figure because for all you know it might
be all for a hundred but they might be
they might be selling it for 65 so if
you're going to say I'll give you 80
you've paid over the odds of what you
could have paid so always make them give
the first figure so don't come in and
say I'll give you 80 how does that sound
or I'll give you 90 or whatever say to
them if I was to give you cash tomorrow
what would be the absolute lowest you
would accept and still live with and
then just shut up until they speak you
know what they're gonna say if they say
oh what's on 400 I'll accept 99 then
there's no point offering six day but if
you offer 80 and they would have
accepted 60 then you screwed as well so
let damn always put the figure in first
so what would be the lowest you could
except and still live with wait for them
to speak now if they absolutely will not
give you a figure and they just like
what what will you offer always try make
them offer first but if they absolutely
will not then put in an offer that you
are embarrassed with okay like a really
embarrassing offer because if they want
a team it's on for a hundred and you
couldn't say six there they go no you've
not lost anything apart from just maybe
looking a little bit cutthroat or
whatever but you've not lost anything so
fine while the true current market value
is make them put the first figure in
first and then thirdly if you have to
put the figure in first do an
embarrassingly low figure once you've
secured a property like that it might it
might take you 20 hours to find more
property like that half a week but if
you manage to get 20 or 30 grams off the
true market value of a property in 20
hours that's like more than a thousand
pounds an hour that you've been being
paid in equity so I think it really pays
to try and get discounted bargaining
properties and of course you want to
make sure that the rental is good as
well to make sure that it stacks up and
other videos on that you can check up up
here just above on this video if you
can't buy the property and they accept
you and you're like oh my goodness I've
just had an offer accepted of 60,000 and
it's worth one hundred thousand but I
can't buy it then who do you know that
can who could lend you the money
maybe you could do a joint venture or
maybe you could pass that D on to
somebody else and charge a finder's fee
it tastes something if you found a
property that was worth one hundred and
you've got it for six day I'd pay you
five thousand ten thousand pounds for it
so there's many things you can do the
world is your oyster when you know how
to find a good property that's like that
I hope that's been helpful please do
subscribe below if it has and don't
forget to smash that like button and
I'll see you next time thank you so much
for watching this video it's mentoring
on a Monday every single week at 7 p.m.
on a Monday between 8 p.m. I'm gonna be
live answering all your comments and
questions don't forget to subscribe
right over here so you'll never miss one
of these videos I'll see you next week
at 7 p.m.
also if you haven't got a copy of my
book you need this in your life you can
get it from Amazon for 10 power 19 iron
or a gift from made absolutely free down
below in the description link I'll see
you next week Monday at 7 p.m.